hi my name is Fabian dufuno and I'll be
talking about dipping shortest path to
hypergraph by appetite decomposition
this is John work with view Valley Mech
and ran Gales first let me go over the
motivations that underlie this work
consider many cheap sensors airdropped
over a large land Zone these sensors
form an unstructured network of simple
devices by simple we mean that these
devices communicate through very basic
Wireless signals in fact through unary
Wireless signals which will call beeps
in these networks we care about
monitoring we have some events that
happen at some nodes one or many which
we'll call Destination nodes I wish to
find paths from a predetermined Source
node to these destination nodes a
now let me Define a model for these
distributed networks and the problem
that that defines this monitoring
application
for the model we consider the BP model a
distributed computing model that was
introduced recently in 2010
this model is inspired by biological
distributed systems and in fact it
models distributed systems with
communication which will include weak
wireless sensor Networks
more formally the BP model represents
the sensor Network as a communication
graph G where nodes represent devices
and edges represent whether two devices
May communicate with each other the
number of nodes is denoted by n as you
can see on the top figure to the right
we have three nodes three devices each
May communicate with the two others and
this is represented by a click
additionally we assume that nodes start
arbitrary or upon hearing a V and that
each node has an ID in one to poly n
time is separated into synchronous
rounds and in each round nodes can
either beep or listen if the node resets
in this round then in the second step it
hears whether zero neighbor speed or at
least one neighbor's B in this round and
finally in the third step the node can
do some computations
and this is in fact very weak
communication model and I will
illustrate it with some examples
on the bottom figure to the right W
beeps and in fact it just it broadcasts
a unary signal to both of its neighbors
it cannot choose to beep on it to you it
has to beep to both u and v
on the other hand
when w listens it cannot distinguish
whether only you is beeping or u n v or
b b
now the BP model has attracted much
attention since it has been introduced
local prompts were studied by that by
local women problems that are fast to
solving a distributed Manner and this
includes maximal independent set and
Delta plus one coloring
but also Global problems from Zara slow
to solving distribute have been studied
so that includes leader election and
multi-broadcast of game messages and in
fact the problem we will consider in
this work is a global problem
and finally one last research direction
that has been recently studied for the
BP model is that of Designing noise
tolerant algorithms
in this work we consider the problem of
computing shortest paths we assume we
have a greater mind Source node and an
arbitrary set of destination nodes and
you have two words that of computing a
single path instead of computing
multiple shorter spots
for the first variant we wish to compute
the single shortest path from the source
to some arbitrary destination
and what do we mean here by compute
especially in the beeping model we mean
here that nodes that are on that path
output 1 and nodes that are not on that
path output 0. for the warrant in which
we compute multiple paths which to
compute multiple shorter spells one for
each destination node and nodes that are
on any of these paths with output one
others should output 0.
let me give two visual examples
first consider the problem of computing
a single shortest path
the orange node is the source node and
the two green nodes are the two
destination nodes here
we compute the shortest path between the
orange node and the top destination node
this is chosen the stop destination node
is just chosen arbitrary we did not set
it to the destination we wanted to
compute a path to
and notes that are between the orange
node
and this top destination node output 1
all of the nodes output 0.
now for the problem of computing
multiple shortest paths with the very
same setting
we can see that nodes between the orange
Source node and the two
destinations that are on the shortest
paths the two shortest paths output one
and all other nodes output zero
Computing shortest path is a global
problem it requires nodes that are far
about to exchange information
and because of that it is easy to show
an Omega of the lower bound
moreover the fact that the message size
is limited implies an Omega flog and
lower bound because of some symmetry
breaking considerations
but together we have a Omega of D plus
log and lower bound on compute the
problem of computing shortest paths
we give two hours one for accompanying
single shortest path and the second for
accompanying multiple shorts path the
first runs in of D log login plus log
Cube and rounds and the second rounds in
of D log squared plus log Cube generates
and we can see that if that the first
is an improvement over the naive uh
algorithm for accompanying a single
shortest path when D is large
and the second is a significant
Improvement on the naive value because
it does not have this dependency on why
so the Y here is a set is the set of
destination nodes so the naive algorithm
has this factor in the number of
destination nodes that are algorithm for
accompanying multiple shortest path does
not
and we can compare this to the lower
bound I just mentioned
and this shows that our algorithms are
not tight
and in fact
it is likely that the lower bound can be
improved to match our outcomes
next I will go into the details of our
algorithm for computing a single
shortest path both of our algorithm and
the naive algorithm follow this simple
General framework first node execute
some pre-processing steps
for example they first compute their
distance to the source and whether they
aren't any shortest path between the
source and the destination
then in the second part they construct
this the shortest path one node at a
time from the source to some destination
initially only the source node is active
and then in phases the active node finds
a neighbor which is one hole closer to
the dentist to the destination and
becomes an active
that neighbor becomes active and is the
next node in the computed path and this
is repeated until some arbitrary
destination is reached
finally nodes output 1 if they were
active at some point in the algorithm
and they output zero otherwise
the name algorithm is obtained by
instantiating this framework as follows
the pre-processing steps are simple and
they follow from previous work so I will
not describe them however the main
difficulty in instituting the framework
even for the naive volume lies in
finding the next node in the computed
path
so assume you have some active node U
which is a distance D from the source it
can have multiple neighbors V1 V2 and so
on at distance D plus one and because we
are using BB communication the active
node cannot easily choose some node VI
it cannot easily tell this node VI that
it is the next node in the computed path
instead we need to perform some symmetry
breaking more concretely neighbors V1 V2
and so on random randomized competition
what do we mean by randomized
competition each of these Neighbors say
VI starts as a candidate and they pick
random bitstreak say x i of T bits and
then there will beep that bit string in
two t rounds in the following manner in
the first odd round for example VI will
be if the first bit of string x i is 1
and if VI is still candidate otherwise
it listens otherwise we are innocence
and in the first even round you will
relay any beeps edit here that you heard
from one of these nodes from the nodes
V1 V2 and so on well VI distance and if
VI did not beep earlier and then here's
a beep from you then there is no longer
a candidate and they do so in all in the
next odd and even rounds for the next
bit and so on at the end of this
randomized computation exactly one node
remains candidate
with probably with high probability and
which means with Priority One minus 1
over n as long as we take T to B Theta
of log n
now for the round complexity of the
naive algorithm you get with this simple
randomized competition
well the pre-processing steps take all
of the rounds I won't go into the
details whereas the constructing the
part where you construct the buff text
of the phases one per node added to the
path
and Theta login rounds per face this is
the cause of the randomized computation
if you put this together the round
complexity of the naive algorithm is D
log n rounds
so how do we improve on the naivagram we
use the following idea we trade off
pre-processing cost and path computation
cost more concretely we use more rounds
in the pre-processing steps to assign to
each node v a small extra label Lov
enables it and SLV
and these label and label set we have
some properties that allow us to be more
efficient in the path computation part
indeed in that part in each phase
during which we compute which is the
next node in the in the shortest path
we have the active node with beep it's
label and display and beeping the label
will be fast because it's it's a small
label and additionally it will also be
the case that for exactly one neighbor
via V the label V is in the label set of
VI so just by listening to the label we
can know which is the next node in the
path
so obviously assigning this label and
label sets makes the best computation
part easy
but it is not clear how to compute these
labels
so how do we compute this label and
label sets let layer LD contain all
nodes a distance D from the source
and for any two layers ldld plus one we
Define a hypergraph HD whose nodes are
the nodes in error LD plus one and whose
Edge is
are the neighborhoods of the nodes in
their D or more precisely their
intersection with LD plus one
and to compute the label and label sets
we solve another problem which we call
hypergraphy appetite decomposition on
all hypergraphs HD
now what is hypographic decomposition
typographic decomposition is the
following problem assume you are given
some hypograph H with vertex set VH and
nhset eh you want to decompose eh into K
disjoint subsets F1 to FK such that the
subhaprograph vhfi are each bipedite by
that I mean that there exists a Vertex
subset U
for each file such that the vertex
intersects each edge of f i in exactly
one node
so you can see in the example below we
have a hypograph with three at with
three hyper edges six nodes the first
hyper Edge contains the first three
nodes the second the last three nodes
and the third hyper Edge contains all of
the nodes and we can decompose this
hypergraph into two disjoint subsets of
edges F1 being the first two edges and
F2 being the last Edge
foreign
decomposition problem or HPD problem we
show The Following Lemma assume you are
given a hypograph with nodes and a
hybrid set which is polynomial and n
then that hypergraph can be decomposed
into Theta of logs current subsets so
this is both an upper and lower ball and
in fact this Lambda can be generalized
to larger hybridged sets but obviously
the number of subsets increase
it remains to Define what it means to
solve the hbd problem in the distributed
setting assume you are given a
hypergraph h
then we want to assign label L Prime of
V to each Edge e of the hypergraph as
well as a possibly empty label set at S
Prime of V to each node V of the hyper
graph and this label and label set
should satisfy the following property
for each edge of the hypergraph its
label our primary V
belongs in the label set as primary of
exactly one node V of the edge
some in the figure below I illustrate to
the left what these label and label sets
would look like
concretely how is the hbd prom used in
the pre-processing steps
first we solve the HPD problem on all
hypergraphs HD
from D starting at 0 to the diameter of
the graph
right
so first thing to note solving the HBO
problem one hypergraph can be done in
the beeping algorithm and it takes
overflow Cuban rounds and I will not go
into the details this in a sense is an
extension of the randomized computation
idea I've shown earlier then
I point out that the hbd prompt can be
run for hypergraphs h0 H3 H6 and so on
simultaneously and this will take
overflow Cuban rounds then once this is
done I can run the HP I can solve the
HPD prompt for H1 H4 and so on
simultaneously and once these are done I
can solve the HPD problem for H2 H5 and
so on simultaneously so that actually
solving the HPD prompt for all layers
for all the hypergraphs text or flow
Cuban routes
after we've completed hbd solutions for
all hyperglass HD we can use this HP
solutions to sign enable and label sets
to all nodes
take the label and label set assigned by
some HPD solution save for hypergraph HD
recall that this hypergraph HD
its nodes are the nodes of layer D plus
1 and its edges are defined by the nodes
of layer D now
for the notes in near G plus 1 we set
their label set to the label set they
obtained in the HPD solution
as for the notes in error D we set their
label not their label set
to the label of the corresponding Edge
in the hypergraph
and if we do this for all hbd solutions
then all nodes except the source and the
destination
gets labels and label sets and
all labels assigned in this way are
integers in 1 to K where K is equal to
is at most log Square n and this is
important because that means the labels
will be small that means they'll have
size log log n
so we've completed these extra label and
label set how does the path computation
component take this into account
look at one phase in which you want to
find the next node in the path
in that phase the active node save V and
say in some layer D beeps each label
love and at the same time the
neighboring nodes of this active node
which are in the next layer they listen
and they check if this label belongs to
their label set
and this condition will hold true for
exactly one note because of the hbd
property
this node just becomes the next active
node in the path and we can see that now
we did not actually need to break
symmetry here we already block symmetry
in the pre-processing steps
and this allows us to find the next one
in the path exponentially faster than by
using randomized computation because
beeping in the label takes only log K
which is of log log in rounds
in summary we increase the number of
rounds required for the pre-processing
steps to O of D plus log Cuban rounds
the extra Log Cabin runs are used to
assign labels and label sets to all
nodes
and these are crucial in reducing the
number of rounds required to construct
the shortest path
indeed constructing the shortest path
still takes all of these phases one per
node added to the path but each phase is
exponentially faster and takes only log
log n rounds
this is due to the fact that we no
longer need to break symmetry but here
we use the labels and label sets
assigned in the pre-processing steps put
together the round complexity of our
algorithm is D Times log log n plus Log
Cabin rounds and this is an improvement
significant Improvement when the
diameter is large
to sum up we give the first non-trivial
beeping algorithms for accompanying
shortest paths both for computing a
single shortest path as well as for
computing multiple shortest paths
moreover we also give the first beeping
algorithm and of D log log in the factor
in round complexity
and a natural open question is whether
that factor is tight and this can be
answered for example by giving a
matching lower bound
finally I want to point out this
hypograph decomposition from which is a
nice graph theory of formulation
that we used that is in fact
surprisingly connected to some
distributed lower bounds on the time
required to broadcast messages in reader
Networks
thanks and I hope you enjoyed the
presentation